i mean i thought it'd be fun to ask you
i don't know if you're paying attention
to the machine learning world and gpt3
so the gpt3 is this language model this
neural network that's able to uh
has 175 billion parameters
so it's very large and it's trained in
an unsupervised
way on the internet it just reads a lot
of
unstructured text and it's able to
generate some pretty impressive things
the human brain compared to that has
about you know a thousand times more
synapses people get so upset
when machine learning people compare the
brain
and like we know synapses are different
it was very different
very different right but like do you um
what do you think about gpt3
here's what i think here's what i think
a few things what gpt-3 is doing is
extremely impressive but it's very
different from what the brain does so
it's a good impersonator but just as one
example
everybody takes a passage that gpt
3 has has written and they say wow look
at this and it's pretty good right
but it's already gone through a
filtering process of humans looking at
it and saying okay well that's crap
that's correct okay oh here's
here's a sentence that's pretty cool now
here's the thing
human creativity is about absorbing
everything around it and remixing that
and coming up with stuff so in that
sense we're sort of like gpt3 you know
we're
we're remixing what we've gotten in
before
but we also know we also have very good
models of what it is to be another human
and so um you know i don't know if you
speak uh french or something but i'm not
gonna start speaking in french cause
then you'll say
wait what are you doing i don't
understand it instead everything coming
out of my mouth is meant for your
ears i know what you'll understand i
know the vocabulary that you know and
don't know i know what parts you care
about
that's a huge part of it and so of all
the possible sentences i could say
i'm navigating this thin bandwidth so
that it's something useful for our
conversation yeah in real time but also
throughout your life maybe you're
you're co-vol we're co-evolving together
we're learning exactly how to uh
communicate together
exactly but this is the this is what
gpt3 does not do
all it's doing is saying okay i'm going
to take all these sentences and remix
stuff and pop some stuff out
but it doesn't know how to make it so
that you lex will feel like oh yeah
that's exactly what i needed to hear
um that's the next sentence that i
needed to know about for something
well of course it could be all the
impressive results we see the question
is when if you raise the number of
parameters
whether it's going to be after something
it will not be
it will not be no raising more
parameters won't
here's the thing it's not that i don't
think neural networks can't be like the
human brain because i suspect they will
be at some point 50
you know who knows but what we are
missing
in artificial neural networks is we've
got this basic structure
where you've got units and you've got
synapses they're connected
and and that's great and it's done
incredibly mind-blowing impressive
things but
it's not doing the same algorithms as a
human brain
so when i look at my children as little
kids
yeah as infants they can do things that
no gpt3 can do
they can navigate a complex room they
can
navigate social conversation with an
adult
um they can lie they can do a million
things they
they are active thinkers in our world
and doing things and this of course i
mean look we totally agree on
in how incredibly awesome artificial
neural networks are right now but we
also know the things that they can't
do well like you know like be generally
intelligent do all these different
reasons reason about the world
efficiently learn efficiently adapt
exactly but it's still the rate of
improvement
it's uh to me it's it's possible they'll
be surprised
like that agree that's what we'll be
surprised but what i would
what i would assert and then and i'm
glad i'm going to say this on your
podcast so we can look back at this in
two years in 10 years
is that we've got to be much more
sophisticated than units and synapses
between them
let me give you an example and this is
something i talked about in livewire is
despite the amazing
impressiveness mind-blowing
impressiveness computers don't have
some basic things artificial neural
networks don't have some basic things
that we
like caring about relevance for example
so
as humans we are confronted with tons of
data all the time and we only encode
particular things
that are relevant to us we have this
very
deep sense of relevance that i mentioned
earlier is based on survival at the most
basic level but then
all the things about my life and your
life
what's relevant to you that we encode um
this is very useful computers at the
moment don't have that they don't have
to have a yen to survive
and things like that so we filter out a
bunch of the junk we don't need
we're really good at efficiently zooming
into the things we need
again could be argued you know let me
put on my freud hat
maybe it's a i mean that's our conscious
mind uh
you know we're not you know there's no
reason that neural networks aren't doing
the same kind of filtration
i mean in the sense what gpt3 is doing
so there's a priming
step it's doing an essential kind of
filtration when you
ask it to generate tweets from
from i don't know from from an elon musk
or something like that it's doing
a filtration of it's throwing away all
the parameters it doesn't need for this
task
and it's figuring out how to do that
successfully and then
ultimately it's not doing a very good
job right now but it's doing a lot
better job than we expected
but it won't ever do a really good job
and i'll tell you why i mean so so
let's say we say hey produce an elon
musk tweet and we see like oh wow it
produced these three that's great but
again
it's not we're not seeing the three
thousand not producing it didn't really
make any sense
it's because it has no idea what it is
like to be a human
and all the things that you might want
to say and all the reasons you wouldn't
like when you go to write a tweet
you might write something you think yeah
it's not going to come off quite right
in this modern political climate or
whatever like you know you can change
things
so it somehow boils down to fear and
mortality
and uh all of these human things at the
end of the day
all contained with that tweeting
experience
well interestingly the fear of mortality
is at the bottom of this but you've got
all these more things like you know oh i
want to
just in case the chairman of my
department reads this i wanted to come
off there just in case my mom looks at
this tweet i want to make sure she
you know and so on so that those are all
the things that humans are able to
sort of throw into the calculation i
mean uh
what it required what it requires though
is having a model
of your chairman having a model of your
mother having a model of the
you know the person you want to go on a
date with who might look at your tweet
and so on
all these things are uh what it is like
to be them
you